Hello, my name is ?Lynn ?Lastname out and I'm going to be having a conversation with Dawn Suvino
for visible lives an oral history project at the New York Public Library.
Today is December 2nd, 2014 .
and this is being recorded at the Andrew Heiskell library.
%um
Tell me something about growing up -- Sure -- where you come from.
Sure. %um So I was born in Plainfield, New Jersey
which is about 28 miles west of New York City.
Uh, most New Jerseyites - or New Jerseyans - say that there are two
parts of Jersey north and south. %Um. But Some %uh
%uh, some folks will argue there's something called Central
Jersey but usually those are people that don't come from New Jersey. Um, so
North Jersey where I grew up, uhm, when I was first, when I was
born, uhm, we lived, actually uh, in Playfields in a
little apartment my mother and father and my first - our first - dog, Bijoux (?), a little
poodle, who I swear I remember my mother always said I only remember it from
pictures because I was so little, I couldn't possibly remember the dog.
But, %um, af-, you know, after a while we moved to a bigger house in a town called
Middlesex -- this is all around the same sort of part of New Jersey, sort of Union
County, Somerset County. And then for a little while
after that we lived there till I was about 2 1/2 or 3 'cause my, my
brother Steven was born at that time. -- When was this, when were you born? -- I was born in
March, 1962. And my brother was born in November of
1964. We moved in with my mother's
mother for a little while while we were... while my parents were searching for a
house where, %um, and a town where they really wanted to
settle. And that was in North Plainfield New Jersey, where I
lived for I'd say, really a year, we lived with my grandmother
and my mother's uncle. %um And -- 'cause I went to
kindergarten in North Plainfield, New Jersey. But then after that we
moved to a town called Watchum, New Jersey which is an Indian word as many
names of towns in New Jersey are, %um, and Watchung you
may remember if you're at all familiar with Orson Welles' War of the Worlds
broadcast that was where the Martians landed.
[laughter] the Watchung Mountains. And there really are mountains. They're small mountains.
mountains but it's a very mountainous area
and I - we lived there from the time I was six
1968 through - till I was about
13 I think I finished 7th grade in Watchum
and then we moved to, back to North Plainfield which
where I
I grew up the rest of my junior high school, high school, and
even after I went off to college, my family lived there until, um
1989 they moved to Florida. I had two
brothers, Stephen who as I mentioned before was born in 1964 and
T.J. Thomas Joseph who was born in 1971. So he was
my little baby brother, and some of my fondest memories
growing up when he was... my parents were divorced when I was
twelve...TJ was about two, um and my mum had to go back to
work um to support the family um and
so I would pick TJ up from daycare which back in those days it was just really
our neighbor who ran a little daycare in her house next door.
So on my way home from school I pick him up and then I had a little baby seat on the back of my
bicycle and I used to ride him all... And all I think about it now I can't imagine how unsafe that was
I mean it was just like a baby seat you know? With a little strap and nobody
wore helmets or anything. But you know I would ride him over the place and you
know it was it was great to have a little baby brother like that I used to cook for
him and you know I'd hold him on my hip while I-- he loved to eat fried egg sandwiches so I
used to make him fried egg sandwiches and I'd bathe him and watch
Bozo the Clown in Magic Garden with him in the afternoons after school.
It's funny to me to think that he's forty three now. Look you know
I haven't seen him [Yeah.] in a very long time. I'm-- completely estranged
from my brother Stephen who clearly has made a
significant effort to distance
himself from the rest of the family no one seems to know why, but
no one can find him. family did... I have a cousin who ran
into him in Florida, so he is still living in the same area but
you know we started talking some trash when Tommy my cousin Tommy and we
went over to him and said, hey, where you been your sisters like to talk to you and he started
steamin starting with some we had a falling out after my mother died we disagreed as I
think unfortunately families often do about different it wasn't anything to do with
are estate such as it was there really was no estate it was just a house
but we had some issues about the way her care
went towards the end of her life and in any case.
He. Started taking up that same nonsense again and Tommy just said you know that
somebody's going to argue with you you should call your sister what do you know
youngest brother T.J. has had a lot of issues with
drug addiction and he's been in and out of jail and in fact
just finished five years in prison. Actual prison which was
an unbelievable nightmare. But.
You know I stuck by him he had burned every bridge he ever had I stuck by him
as best I could until they finally burned my bridge to just about a month
ago I haven't talked to him since. That's unfortunate and I suddenly
realize my little baby brother and I still worry about him but you know at some point you know
I had to say I can't keep you know I was just constantly sending him money and
he had one story after another and eventually I just realized because I
was talking my father about it because T.J. would text my father and asked for my first
require me to ask for money then he text my father asked for money and it was one story or
another and I finally said you know what this this is just a story is this you know is me
making this stuff up and I you know I can't just keep supporting them and I told them so
much I said you know you need to.
All those years in prison and I send money and I helped you out and I wrote
letters and sent you pictures and what you clothes and you know all
of that and when you got out you said oh I'm going to pay you back and all I said
was the only thing to pay me back is just stand on your own and be on your
own and stay clean and sober and keep you know working and I'm
. The kind of relationship did you know where we were
I mean like I said he was you know nine years younger than me so
we were I mean Stephen and I were very very close by my brother Stephen is two
years younger than me until we got into those weird teenage years
when he first I don't want him hanging around and then by the time I was like eighteen
nineteen and I wanted to hang with him again he was sixteen seventeen eighteen one. We hang around.
But T.J. it was always my little brother and they when I
first came here to New York into college you know I remember having
him out for a weekend to stay with me. You know he you know
I I think I went out on the bus and got him and brought him back and
you know we he stayed with me and went to a party at the door you know with me and
they were he was like nine years old it was great to show off my little baby brother you know.
So we were very very close but you know I mean he was the
youngest son in a family.
Where I think my mother felt very guilty
about the fact that he had a totally different upbringing
than Steve and like my parents were married and frankly were happily
married. My mother always said to the first you know twelve years of her marriage
we're very happy. It was just the last couple of years where things went bad and then ended
. But. You know and we had money we
were upwardly mobile but we lived. What is a very nice
you know Tony type town good schools I was
part of why my mother chose it. Very progressive schools beautiful
homes we had a gorgeous big ranch house on a nice lot
and one of them was a stay at home mom I mean and she loved that role
. She you know she'll be coming to her house every day
and she cleaned every you know every day. She cleaned the house once a week she quit she did the
floors once a week she did. There were like I think there were twenty four windows and that she did in the
windows once a week you know she had a woman come in to help her but you know my mother enjoyed her
her house too much baked she. You know she was
P.T.A. mom you know she went on all the trips everybody she was the cool mom everybody liked
you know so that's the other really interesting thing about my mother for me was you know
especially after the divorce you know I really saw her as such a
strong. You know single woman and this
of course you know was at a time when feminism was really.
On you know exploding it right. So my parents divorced in the late one
nine hundred seventy four. I think the first issue of Ms
Magazine came out of seventy two seventy three on it I would have
been right around the time and Marlo Thomas free to be you and me and you know this was this
was a wonderful time to be on television
what was in it for me was having an abortion I mean I don't think you could do that
day on television have a main character decide to have an abortion you know because
of an unwanted pregnancy
. You know.
So I saw my mom as somebody who was you know even though she had
made the choice to be a stay at home mom and then when
. When she couldn't keep that
choice because she divorced and my father I mean I've reconciled with him since
but you know he was kind of a deadbeat dad he didn't you know support us at all he took
off we didn't even know where he was for a really long time. But
she had to go back to work and she had to take care of us and she did it you
know and she just made the change so. You know
and she didn't she went back to her maiden name that was unheard of. You
know she went back to her maiden name and she didn't ask for
alimony. She also she has for which child support. You know the judge asked her
in her divorce proceedings because my father contested the divorce lawyers
and the judge is finally Well you know one album that I
wanted my name and one is money. I just wanted to take care of his kids you know.
What's. Kind of especially interesting to me too is that I also
had my mother we had one brother and he was twelve
years older than than her and his wife
letter to Helen was. The most amazing
role model to me. Like like I just started my mother's brother and Helen
were. Like something. There were something like really sophisticated and cool about
them. Like when you go to their house like she always had she always
had.
A Coca-Cola like real Coca-Cola not shop or a trade and going
away you know. So so Coca-Cola for us and she had a Pepperidge Farm pizza
flavored goldfish which I thought was such an exotic snack you know
Bridgewater New Jersey. Which.
You know it's pretty much same basic part of New Jersey. About
half an hour thirty minutes from where we lived by color and they had a nice big
split level house. I love that house and they were very popular in the sixty's and seventy's
I think. Later when Helen would sell it because they divorced too often she she had a hard time
because they were not those houses were not popular anymore but I really I really dug that
house. People don't like houses with stairs you know my mom chose the house we didn't want
to have with it was a ranch house. I haven't you know and it was a very pretty house
. So on one level with a couple of places where there was one step up
into the kitchen from the dining room and there were there was a mud
room from the back porch and that had three little steps to go up to where
the bedrooms were all along slightly different levels but
I always liked you know houses that had an upstairs and a downstairs and
a basement and a yard I mean it's I think one of the hardest things moving in New
York is just the lack of space that you have you know how do you work.
Yes You know we had in Washington we had a big backyard and
like woods and oh. In North
Plainfield We also had a pretty big backyard but there were those
houses where they weren't quite rowhouses but they were right next to each
other you know kind of houses with a hedge or whatever in between
but what did you enjoy doing when you were by bike. My bike I love to
ride my bicycle I mean obviously this was before I lost my sight on
but I really I mean I just constantly was riding my bicycle
especially in water because of all that the gorgeous on
it was still a very not quite rural but it was
. Sort of a suburb it you know it once stood. There were
parts of the town. Now it's been built up much much more with developments and all but there were
lots of woods and it was easy to ride from
walked into the farm country. You know Jersey
get such a bad rap from New Yorkers and it's just you know I'm over it because
New Jersey was a great place to grow up and you got the benefits of living so close to New York
I mean my mom and I used to come into New York all the time when I was a kid.
We saw especially over the summer as we used to see placemat
knees all the time and I saw the original production of Pippin
Chicago of A Chorus Line of you know so many things
. And. All. But yet we
still lived in a part of the country where you know you could ride your bicycle for
hours and stop and Myra feel the butterflies you know
or catch you know were catch little frogs you know when you're in a
time that you know I can remember like stumbling
across like apple orchards just riding my bike through the you know there was horse
country out there you know they could stop and just watch horses running and it was really
wonderful. So I'd love to ride my bicycle and go on even
after I lost my sight which I was fifteen when I lost my sight.
My mom when you're bored. What the tandem bike so my brother
Stephen I used to ride a tandem all over the place. We even
went one summer we went to Long Branch for a long time.
Yet for a couple of weeks a friend of my mom's had bought a really nice old kind of hotel
. So I mean yeah yeah and we went to the Jersey
Shore for the summers but it wasn't Long Beach Island now that I'm
thinking of it but in any case it was a joke. A beautiful Jersey Shore down and
like like with us you know and I remember Steve and I
rode the whole length of the island back and forth on that bike just
as you know as a great time you know.
I've tried out a few years ago.
I tried to ride a tandem and I think there is something wrong with the bio
at least of my ex-wife and I both we rent we had found a place where we could rent
one and they brought it down to Chelsea Piers and we were writing it and
I mean I think that was we don't think there was just something wrong with the bank it didn't seem
stable and we can actually fall but I can
feel it. Like we were going to fall. So that was the last time I tried and
you know what. I've had issues with balance and you know
orientation and things like that ever since losing my sight on because I
was bisexual or even illness I had meningitis when I was a
teenager and it was a very very bad form of meningitis
. Actually up to cockle meningitis which is a
bizarre thing for a healthy fifteen year old to get
because they they've got that's when they really didn't see cases of
cryptic meningitis in the developed world.
They eventually started seeing it in people with AIDS like significant
numbers of people with AIDS having Cryptical committed this they were going to get a garden
. Not only so apparently airborne and that
there are people who people can breathe it in.
It's carried by pigeons so you know if if you've been around and then
I can't tell you how many times doctors came into my hospital room to say where you live around
pigeons you know when I was in a teaching hospital and so was like residents and I was like
no one knew where he was even before they come in you know soon as they walk in I didn't know I was not around
significant numbers of pigeons you know.
But but the fact is because it's an opportunistic infection you know
healthy people should be able to fend it off. Now the thing
is I had a terrible cold. It was
September like October or November of one thousand nine hundred seventy
six. Maybe even December right. And I just I
had this cold and it was hanging around and it was it just didn't want to
go away. And
eventually. It did go away
. But then a few months later like
. After my fifteenth birthday and orders. I start having just terrible
headaches really bad eggs and my mom took
me to different doctors. You know
they thought maybe they were stress related. On.
Headaches. It was kind of a stressing kid you know. How did
she get her in you know whatever. So they
thought maybe it was monotone with a teacher you know the end but everything they tested for
nothing. They couldn't figure it out. Any event I mean
eventually I was just so sick. I mean I was insanely sick I
mean I couldn't lift my head off the pillow without
vomiting. You know I couldn't I couldn't eat anything. Like I just
couldn't you know couldn't take pills and I would just regurgitate
. And. You know I don't think
it went on super long but I don't really have a
clear timeline. And you know I
guess I could ask my aunt my Aunt Helen about it but I was going to say pretty much any anybody
who went through it with me is either dead or I'm
not really in touch with them anymore but I do know that. I
but I don't I think it was May of one hundred seventy seven when I went into the
hospital. My mother took me to a neurologist. She took me
to the emergency room and she just said This kid is really sick you have to do
something for her and they gave me like a
shot of morphine or something really strong and they said Take
this neurologist in the morning. And all so I went to the neurologist
. They didn't gene. And this is very hazy in my
memory because I was so so sick. I mean my mother and uncle who
were living with my mother and her uncle. You don't have to like
what Carol must carry me out to the core and then as soon as I sat in a car
just fell asleep. You know I would just fall asleep constantly because I was in so much
pain. That's what your body does right it just says go to sleep now because you're
in pain you know. So they'd rather just do what they did
the E.G. they said. There was something wrong in my brain
. But they didn't know why and they were going to admit me to the hospital. And they
waited they could not admit me until Monday that was like a Thursday
. And I don't know why they waited.
It had something to do with the hospital and what my mom wanted me to go on
to at the time it was Oswald Raritan Valley Hospital that was affiliated
with workers medical school. Which is a good choice because you know you
want to be at a teaching hospital all if you carry. On.
And the hospital the other hospital and playfield Newlander hospital which
is where I was born and my mother was born and you know everybody I know was born
on you know there's nothing wrong with a hospital just wasn't as nice you
know. So anyway.
I was sort of sick and all through that week and I was terribly sick
and when I woke up and at that point my vision was kind of blurry
but I just assume I mean I just felt like it was because I was I wasn't eating I was
delirious sleeping constantly I felt like I was constantly in
this state of semi weakness you know.
So when I woke up one morning and was going to go to the hospital and I went to
get out of bed. And I couldn't move the left side of my body
I just couldn't move it at all and so I yelled to my mom
. And she and my uncle Steffi came and helped me get into the
restroom. We just thought it was just too weak you
know. But I could not move any part of the left side of my body so
they clearly ended up calling me you know the I'm an ambulance to take me to the hospital
and over the course of the next four or five days my
system just started to shut down. By Tuesday Monday
or Tuesday Tuesday I guess I couldn't move any part of my body at all
. I was also Mike so I was disappearing. In a
totally strange way it was as if someone was pulling the shade or
a window shade down from top to bottom on my my eyes and I could
only see out of the bottom half of my eyes and then eventually I couldn't and that would get
blurry and then I could and then I couldn't see any more at all. I
also why my lung collapsed and they put me on a respirator
. And on. I went into. A coma
pretty much. I think it was not any kind of deep coma because I do
have. Sort of semi.
Surrealistic recollections of things that happened during the time that I was
out. But. It was like things would be
happening but I didn't know exactly what they were so I would make up
. Like. Fantasies around what was really happening for example I was
running fevers of like one hundred eighty degrees on and I
guess the nurses would come. And you know give me a spare us or
whatever you know just you know and I have in my sort of
bizarre semi comatose state I imagined that I was
like in a sarcophagus that was like a red clay sarcophagus
that would grow on me. Little by little it start to suffocate me
. And then these angels would come and show me they would have like a
plain like a you know like a you know a plane a plane a door with and they
would shave the clay off of me little by little and I would feel some relief
and it was only after I had woken up and realized what was happening that
that was the fantasy there was another time they were doing some surgery on my right
lung. And. I remember hearing the doctors talking
but not really putting together like what was going on and thinking
I was being experimented on.
I thought being a good Catholic girl I thought I don't I didn't go to hell you know.
And I am going to let you know. But of course when you're fifteen you think well what every you
know you lied to your mother or you you know you smoke too much pot or you do this or
that so that's why you're in hell you know where you stop going to church you know because like I stopped going to
church when I was like thirteen.
But when I woke up which was quite quite a bit of time
later on and I I said all right now to my mother I couldn't talk
because of the respirator but I said how long I've been here and she said
you know eight weeks so I was pretty much out for just about two months
. Old and empathizing.
So. And you know people say to me
all the time wow that must have been such an you know hard thing to wake up and you know because
I was blind I was paralyzed I was on a respirator so I couldn't talk
on. I couldn't move couldn't you know what I could do was think it here you know
anybody mouthing words was it took people time to figure because you know had said
paralysis that my face was dropping you know. But
you know I swear to God The thing you think when you wake up and I've talked to other people
at car accidents things like you know think oh shit on blind you know we're on our allies
. You just think I'm alive thank God I'm alive you know a
leader Right This Minute starts to sink in and you realize you
know that you're stuck with this and that's that's difficult but but
don't you know and. I. Somehow the way I remember it.
My mother was there and Helen was there and you
know and maybe even my uncle Gus but it
probably was only my mother you know maybe maybe not I mean you know because I was in
intensive care during that time so they probably were all there very often I don't
when I mean my mother was an appeasing when I was in hospital for eight
months and the whole time. I mean after I became a waiter writing
me if I woke up and she was working she would stop and I was on her
way to work to see me she would spend her lunch hour with me and
all the day and she'd stop back at the hospital before going home after work
and she'd go home and make my brothers their dinner and then
she'd come back and spend you know that sometimes my brothers would come. Usually I would come see him and not
so much. He was I was fifteen he was later teens.
But T.J. was five so he came all the time.
And all that and she was relieved our evening with me you know every day and
I don't I don't know how she did it.
You know did you talk with her or your brother's afterwards about what this
means.
You know not so much I thought of my family is a
very in many ways very close but there wasn't a lot
of. Talking about. Feelings and emotions at
one point. In the ninety's. I probe
. A little bit tongue in cheek I wrote my last will and testament
because I was such a great place in my life and I was so happy and you know
again being Catholic or being raised Catholic
I was like oh shit
. Something terrible is going to happen to me because I'm just.
It was going to grade my career was great I mean I wasn't really in a
relationship but you know I felt like no one was coming you
know I had been in a relationship that and sort of
you know happily in the late eighty's early ninety's so by the
ninety's I was just you know sort of out over it and happy and Anyway
so I noticed last will and testament and I you know I told my mother and
my brothers especially you know a huge part of that I commented
to certain people things that I thought about them and you know I told my brothers how
sorry I was if you don't ever. They felt that you know I
and I know they must have felt that I got more attention and
more.
All there was you know given to me.
Because of my disability you know more attention more.
Your people went out of their way to make sure. You know I got.
The things they thought I needed or should. All and I'm sure there were times when
my brothers felt that they were neglected. In
fact during that time I was in the hospital at one point in the summer. Late summer
was like August my mom told me that she was going to take the boys to the sure for a
week. But that she had arranged you know I had lots of friends that would come to the hospital and my
uncle stepped on in such a hell and all these people would come and go you know
so I was never going to be alone and I remember really feeling resentful and even at the time
thinking you know you jerk I could have been resentful she said you know she spends all her
time with Hero and neglect your brothers and yet you know
you're resenting the fact that she's going to go away for a week but I think that's something.
I've struggled with all of my life is the sort of feeling of abandonment and
I'm sure it comes from you know my parents' divorce I was I
loved my father very much not that I didn't love my mother but you know I
was the first born. I was. The only girl
. And I mean my daddy and I were so so close I used to
you know used to drive. Around to whatever you know whatever instead and then run going to the
barbershop doing this and that and I would I would sit right you know on the front seat right next
to him and he had a convertible which was fun and he always let me play
my Wizard of Oz eight track you know and that was great and he carefully played my
Wizard of Oz you know over and over again. Well one of the most amazing things he did for
me was turn me on to Frank Sinatra from a very young age so I always love a Sinatra
and I was because my dad is listening to Frank Sinatra in the car. So when he when
my parents split up and my father pretty much disappeared
right on. I believe my mother you know I blame my
mother for it. I mean I think that's probably a really common thing.
But I also think that I was I remember or with my
mother at one point and I'm going to go live with daddy and Norm person go ahead. You
know. But I agree even at the time thinking that he doesn't want me to come up with him
you know you know where he was at the time the front or at first when they first had
separated Yes he was still living in the area. But you know
he that's how we got back in touch with him he had left I would say. So they
split up right around one hundred seventy four seventy five.
And. Probably around seventy five and then he
took off by seventy six he was gone we didn't know where he was
. But I and then I got sick
. In seventy seven.
And he called my mother. And said that he wanted to come see
me.
But that he was afraid she would have him arrested for you know lack of support.
And she of course being the amazing independent strong woman that she
was just said No I think it's more important because your daughter I'm not going to. Do anything to
hurt you know to go after you or anything so I guess it turned out that you know we had friends
that still lived in the area and somebody had called him and said you know your daughters really really sick.
So then I said you know I got back in touch with him he came up to visit me
you know. And. You know and I and I when I was eighteen I
went he was living in Florida he still lives in Florida. You know I went down to visit him
. And it was just great to have this renewed
relationship with my father and I kept that relationship probably from the
time I was eighteen fifteen sixteen until I
was.
Maybe twenty two twenty three mid twenty's.
Even I guess a little later. And then I. Hear
. Two things happened really that made me stop. Responding
to him because he would call and I would either. Scream the call you know through
the old answering machines order. And not take the call or he'd write
send me a birthday card or something and I just ignore it.
But the two things that happened one I started to really think
about. What he had done to us that he had just
left us you know that he just didn't. You know.
Think. Like you know my feminist nature came up I started thinking he
just you know I have these children and then left you know we just left us
to be raised by my mother all by herself and
didn't you know.
Didn't make it easy restitution you know or or whatever and
I and I. Sort of fell. Out of respect for my mother you know
screw Viendo who's hita if I can.
Get my attention or my love and affection.
That was. The. Version of the story I told
myself. Mostly. I think the reality was that
by nine hundred twenty S. was when I really
realized that I was a lesbian. And I began to
act. On you know on the fact that I was a lesbian but I
was still sleeping with men you know at first I think this is very common
bisexual I get by not being you know pinned down by labels or whatever but
even in my mid twenty's I knew I could you know I was not attracted to
men. And I was only attracted to women. And
somehow. I didn't know how to tell my father.
That. Now the great irony is
. That my father remarried when he was in his
late forty's so around one thousand eighty seven so around the same time
. That I was you know realizing what was going on in my life
and he you know Gayle his wife had two small children
from a previous marriage and raise those children. You know like I
said I've recently gotten back in touch with my father in that scene and I feel very close to him and our
kids are great as his stepchildren are great and I'm glad to have a family
a step brother to step sister and brother in law and sister in law but you know
my father's sister in law Gail sister was a lesbian and
they just love I mean they love that she's passed away unfortunately she did get sick
ovarian cancers. But some. So my
father was totally would have been totally fine with it and at some point after
my mother died my mother died in two thousand and two on
. My brothers kind of got back in touch with my me my father kind of got back in
touch with all of us and because my brothers were living in Florida they lived on the west
coast of Florida My father lives in a Fort Lauderdale East Coast area they went
to see him on like Thanksgiving and stuff. After my mom passed and
I guess Billy told him I was a lesbian and he called
me and he did and at that moment I was living with Elizabeth
. My my ex-wife who you know I got together with we got together in January
two thousand and one and so you know my mom died in two thousand and
two so in October two thousand and two so you know it was probably you know
around the time December of two thousand and two when my dad called me and
what exactly remember how he said it but he basically
said something without saying the word lens of the Union or Gary
or he just basically said you know it's it's fine with me I really would like to see you and read a
little bit you know. I was the same thing though when I told my mother. Right so
. So my first really significant relationship with a
woman was with a woman named Jackie and it started in one thousand nine
hundred eighty seven. And we lived together from eighty
seven through eighty eight and we actually moved to Philadelphia together
because.
I was going to go to graduate school at University of Pennsylvania was going to be a Ph
D. there. So on we moved to
Philadelphia in July of one thousand nine hundred seventy you know Tip Don't ever
move to Philadelphia in the middle of the summer it's you know I did so.
It's with the rivers it's just unbearable. Black In any case
. So. Everyone there are you know from eighty seven
eighty nine and when the relationship sort of ended
in eighty nine and I moved back to New York shortly thereafter but
during that time in one thousand eighty eight my mother's uncle who Michael Steffi was mentioned
several times we lived with him you know we moved in with him when my parents divorced and
. He was you know really it was really like a father figure to me even
though he was much older because he was my mother's uncle and he was like a father figure to
her too because her parents divorced when she was six months old but I mean he
might misstep he died in one thousand nine hundred eight October of eighty eight. So on
.
We he and Jack you know invited my mom and Stephen and T.J. down to
Philly.
For on.
Thanksgiving and me and she is a chef actually went to the Philadelphia
restaurants.
And and I mean we had you know this big beautiful apartment because it's Philadelphia
and you can afford it but of course you know there was one bedroom and one bed and you know
it I mean. So I you know. I don't know how
I deluded myself into thinking that somehow my mother didn't know I was a lesbian right
. But I remember when I moved back to New York in eighty nine
. And it's funny it was right around Thanksgiving time that this happened. I
moved back in the summer of eighty nine. But. So I am one of the
things I wanted to do was get connected with the community. Right because I was in school
anymore. Right I didn't mean people I didn't just you know lovers or partners
but I mean the people you know you meet them through school or through work and I was
working on went freelance and poured time and so I I started
a lot of different groups at the Gay and Lesbian Center which was like a cell
G.B.T. center.
Q X Y Z.
No alphabet so but I joined what was then called gay and lesbian
independent Democrats has a different name now I can remember of it. I started
volunteering for the lesbian switchboard which while that seems like
such an archaic thing now that people would actually sat in his little room and people would
call and ask a question and he would have to look in a book to give the
information you know about things you know and
that's you know not you know not even twenty one twenty
.
Twenty some odd years about less than twenty five when you were talking about
it you know you were trying to write for me
.
I had a little laptop buy an old laptop with business
vision and so I put the most common things in like a Word
Perfect file on my laptop and then I had like some other
general numbers that they could call if I didn't have the really specific
information.
So that's how I did it.
And also in the very beginning they actually And then they did this to everyone when you first
start you go through kind of a probationary period and you work with somebody
else so there was another person there and they were all obviously sighted
.
So they could look in the book for me. But a lot of the course
information course they were. Not quick crisis calls but just
sad and lonely people calling. So you just kind of talk to people you know
. Or gave advice you know. On. Peer
counseling kind of stuff. But but anyway so I was doing
all this stuff and. I was thinking you know I really want to tell my
mother that lets me and I have gone to a workshop and identity
house on internalized homophobia. And
really was really enlightening because I was thinking about that I thought you know
all your friends know you're a lesbian anyplace you ever work or go to
school. You're complete you know you're out. And that's so funny
because I was just saying to somebody today you know out what does that even mean
anymore like. Like is anybody in the same way closeted anymore I mean I
guess that's all filtered through the perspective of New York so
but but anyway for my mother this long letter telling
her about you know that I'm a lesbian and I first realized this when
really when I was in college even though if I look back I knew it I knew it when I
was a teenager but you know I didn't know what it was exactly and
. And that I wanted to be honest with her and tell her about you know all
these groups I was joining and how it was so great to be connected to a community
and that you know Jackie had and she didn't Jackie because we were together two years you know so I mean my
mom knew Jackie really well right. So. You
know I see you know the jacket was really the first significant relationship by it handed
you know that I wanted to be open and honest and I remember what I was living on Bleecker and
Thompson I was looking out onto the streets between Bleecker and House to it and I
remember walking over to the mailbox. I think it was I think it was on the corner of
Bleecker. And I dropped that letter in the mailbox
I remember panicking thinking what if everything I know
to be true about this woman isn't true what if somehow she too has to
include believing you know somehow I'm not a lesbian. I mean you
know and what if you know she doesn't she stopped loving me. You know I
don't think that you know but. That was
what was underlying all of it right. What if. What if she hates me now because I
think you know people of a certain e is that that's what we were afraid of
him coming out. What if people don't like us anymore you know. And
especially family you know that's you know people that this was the height of the AIDS crisis
people were. Being disowned by their families you know
. And it was. Like the
Monday before Thanksgiving that I that they sent a letter.
And on. The phone rings. When that Wednesday morning
and some and this again free you know free caller ID or anything. And
somehow I knew it was my mother I just you know it was a ring
.
And I picked it up I said hello. And my mother said Dawn. And
I said Hi mom. And she said Listen honey I got your
letter.
And. I know you're a lawyer. I
am. And I you
know if this makes you feel better to have you know written this letter I'm really
glad that you know and you know and I'm so glad that you've been in these
joining these groups.
Sounds very interesting. You know and I mean it was just amazing you
know and. You know now I think about I think how could I you know
I never thought that you know she didn't know where that anybody didn't know
you know it's so I don't know but but so that
was a big piece of what made me. Stop talking my father for a long time
too. It's amazing how much. That.
That kind of. Fear. Because with
disability with your disability there are some people that you know don't
don't like you because you're disabled. Blind. Which
by the way for the record you know I fortunately took recover everything
other than my eyesight and I have balance issues on which
probably has to do with having been paralyzed but eventually I did get
back on my feet started with being able to when the right time and then kick my
foot my friends would come and say let's see that kick with knife
and then you know after I left the hospital and I had physical therapy and
everything is possible but then for they I went to a rehab center for about
a week but I pleaded please not have to stay in that rehab I promised I'd
come every day after school and I did January of ninety seventy eight I
rejoined my class at north point of high school and
graduated in one thousand nine hundred time with my class.
But three hundred seventy eight every day after school I went to children's specialist
hospital and now inside New Jersey and got physical therapy and occupational therapy so that
eventually I was able to to walk in you know one
which I really run is on the beach like I love to run on the beach because you know.
That's about it you could just sort of run in the surf sometimes but other than
that I do. Where.
Do you. React to
that
. Well you can mix with your friends I mean that was really interesting so
. My best friend at the time I had two best friends ones a woman named Kelly
McCann or what I actually saw a woman younger I mean we were told fifteen were
teenagers. And my best friend my
best best friend was a guy named Michael Scott Sara and Michael
.
Remained a really good friend through all. Of
It. Eventually we had a little falling out but that was not related to the
blindness so much. Everything's related to the blindness in one way or another I'm convinced
of that. It's just like you can't say you know it has nothing to do with being a woman.
Everything has something to do with being a woman on. And I think a blindness
especially but on I so. I hung out
with a crowd of girls that. You know smoked in the
bathroom and cut classes and.
You know were.
You don't run around their hands with boys and drink and Bob
Right because once was I happen to be really smart and so I was like an
accelerated classes and stuff like that but I was still one of the mean girls
you know. Well most of those
girls. Really didn't handle. The blindness very
well. And I ended up getting. New friends.
MICHAEL Like I said stay friends. I hoped so. Besides kind of the cool
girls. I had also these other friends who were more
like smart girls but not cool girls so in the future worlds and high school right
. Well it was kind of great because I got to
. Be popular and be smart and you know be on the newspaper and
you know do all kinds of cool stuff but. But so will
the other girls the smarter girls the girls and whatever they do. They
stuck around and I and I got to know more of them but we really ended up
happening. When I went back to school. In seventy
eight September of seventy eight or so I
started making friends with upperclassmen because they could handle it.
That right I was a sophomore at that time because I was a freshman and when I got
sick. But the experience that changed me and
really. I think. Was very significant
I was in.
College. And must have been the fall of seventy
eight. On. My girl.
And my friend Dana who have been just someone I adored I had a big crush on her own. So
right on I don't think I really realized I had a crush on her she was she was the
older sister of my friend Leslie and Dana was like the class
. Actress You know she was like and you know musical plays and
she used to come to the hospital and sing to me she had a wonderful powerful young woman's voice
on. But anyway Michael Dana and I were going to go
see a benefit concert at Douglas College which is part of
Rutgers University and it was a benefit for Bill Bradley and we really wanted
to go because they're not ready for prime time players we're going to be there in the Chevy
Chase and Gilda Radner and Lucy and so on. Paul
Simon was also there which was cool. Melissa Manchester what I liked very
much right now. I think what you know and go on
and a group called the Patti Smith Group which I've never heard of.
So we get to the concert incident like this auditorium. And you know
the bleachers and then everybody smoked everywhere and like we were smoking cigarettes
and I mean Michael Tina did the song and all these young college kids were coming around
with you know as tracing put that out you can't smoke at the other tour you know whatever it
was very docile crowd I remember I was wearing blue carpenter genes human
genes they have like a little hope on the side of your leg where you can hang
out our cars I have those on and a little pink sort of terry
cloth you know almost like a golf shirt type of a thing.
The very sort of preppy preppy and sneakers probably
.
And.
So we're not ready for prime time players. Some little sting curtain and Gilda
Radner and I was fine. But the
crowd and I went down to the stage they have these barricades up so nobody could get
close to the stage but the crowd was like this. Sort of more
menacing kind of crowd and it didn't seem like they were college
students mostly I mean we were sitting way up like in the bleachers so we were away from the
people on the floor that seemed like they were.
You know just like troublemakers in a way. So
. You know it's her nose. Manchester came out sang a little bit by the time
Paul Simon came out. And he was singing something like Bridge Over Troubled Water and he was
singing a huge hit The crowd was chilling.
Me. Me me.
Then they just basically bowed Paul Simon off the stage and he just stopped
singing with this guitar he said Ladies and gentlemen the Patti Smith Group and Patti came
out. And in microphone she spend a lot of people down in
front and from nothing on the stage and the audience on the ground just
totally ripped out all the barriers and just got up to the state and she
started singing the song called privilege set free. And the
opening lines or something like I see it all before me. Days of days of
love and torment nights of rock and roll but I can't remember because I
. Want to old remember song lyrics
. So what it was she was singing about she had apparently earlier that
year she had fallen off the stage tripped on. A cord.
And flew off the stage and broke her neck and she had been you know wearing a neck
brace and so the tour was that the previous year was called an
attraction back in action and I guess the drummer G.D. dourly had
written this song for Patti and it was about.
You know what it's like or at least to me what it was like
to get sick or hurt and.
Your life changed. Right.
And. I was just I was mesmerized and couldn't
believe what I was hearing. And I mean that experience
. It turned me from a sort of a potential preppy to a
punk in a matter of moments moments.
I immediately you know went out and bought Patti Smith
albums. I started reading her poetry and one day Michael and I
shared a locker in high school and one day he was getting something out of the locker and I don't know
about in your high school like art school people always hung up pictures inside their or their locker you
know and he was going something and I had these pictures of Patty
.
In the locker and this woman Julie was walking much at all like
your picture as you pointed out with me. And Michael said that stones
which Emp and Jenny because there are you know pays for this from
New Jersey anyway and there were just party girls all over Jersey high schools at this
time and she said that one thing is a patty thing because I was
still kind of dressing like a little preppy you know because what I know I didn't know
. Punks were dress I mean punk was still pretty new you know in seventy eight
. I mean I guess it started around seventy five
forty five do you.
Not in England because people like to pretend is an American
just like most musical genre but it has to go to England to get sort of.
You can verify it or whatever and then the stupid Americans decide that they like it but anyway
punk was a New York thing. So
. Cheney and I were in a class together
. I can't remember what it was an elective class because she was a year or they were she and her
friend me where you're ahead of me.
And all but I mean when I started hanging out like crazy and B. and her
friends and and then she took me shopping we can remember we
came into work and we went to like a bunch of thrift
stores and Army Navy stores and you know I got a
bunch of punky clothes you know she was the one who is used to doing with
it exactly exactly and then I started getting a sense of it myself to you
now.
But the funny thing I mean it has to be so how was my relationship with Fred so so I thought I was just
like being friends with all these upper classman.
And Michael I don't mind it and then but then they would
graduate and I was like Taylor graduated two years before me and I had
one from rich who I was friends with to they only he wanted to I think even to move
before that. On me or what would go off to college and you know even though we
would write a little bit you know it wasn't the same. So then I will make friends with people
who are you know if I was a junior I would make friends with people who are seniors but then they put me
graduate so. So eventually
by senior year. I was sort of
forced to go back to the girls who you know I hate to say it
ended me because I don't think that's really what happened I just
think. For the most part most of them weren't really
. Able to sort of deal with this big change I mean we
were all driving right. They all had boyfriends they
all. You know I had jobs
. After school jobs. You know and I think it was hard for them
you know I didn't work I didn't drive I didn't have a boyfriend. You
know I was there for you. Well it was OK because I you know I had my
for my upperclassman friends you know. On. So
when I when I when senior year came along it first will seem new year for me and
I know a lot of people had really shitty experiences in high school I did a lot of my
high school I love my teachers I love my classes on.
You know I loved high school on I was popular. I was more popular after I was
born because I was the only black kid you know. There actually were two other
. Girls who were legally blind. But. I have one
of mine you know pretty well what the other one is a good friend also a good friend of Michael's. But
I didn't know her till we all three. Michael and she and I walking
to N.Y.U. for college so I got to know her better
. And after college and actually she was the first
woman I ever kissed that's what I say or name because I don't know where it.
Was a very distinctive but I don't know where she is.
I've been married I've no idea. But they
. But you know so I started you know hanging back with my old
girls you know. So I still hang out with that angel all day and moved here to New York the
year you know they graduated the year before me but I would come out to see them in New York or if they were
home in North Plainfield I'd see them but you know there was a huge punk movement. I mean
there were so many punks on that I just started being friends with
lots and lots of new people who were punks you know. There was a
whole group of guys that I was really friendly with who were you
know punks. And
. So you know and then with the senior year was really quite
magical I mean everybody was kind of friends with everybody. All that bullshit about
clique's And this nature seemed to really melt away and people you found
yourself hanging with people that you had never really hung with before you
know you you know you know you'd be sitting on a bench in the
you know in the back of the school and somebody else that you didn't really know was there and he just started
talking or because you were you were growing up ready or getting ready to go off to
college and to be independent people you know
. So. You know there were I mean there
were some dark days right from the time. Being in
the hospital and being so so sick and then
. Going back to school. You know
it I mean I was I mean when I realized that I wasn't ever
going to see again. For. Weeks I lay in that
hospital bed and I would just. Hysterically all day every
day and just wrote separately because I couldn't
you know find a garbage pail because you know even I mean I couldn't you know I wasn't mobile enough
to get to one so I would just weep and. Blow my nose and throat
. Because the you know the thing is the whole time I
was in the hospital.
You know I kept getting better right first I couldn't move I couldn't talk and I couldn't
breathe on my own and I couldn't eat I had an easel gastric tube which is how they fed me you
know and then little by little they took me off the respirator and I could and then when that the hole in
my throat started to heal I was able to you know talk again you know in a very speedy voice
but you know eventually I could talk and when the power as the paralysis started to go away
even then before I could talk people could read my lips easier because you know a lot I didn't
have the paralysis and I started building my feet and kick in and then walking
with a walker and then you know I would actually just walk in
. So I just thought well of course I'm going to be able to see you know and I
guess nobody. Thought to tell me no that's not going to
happen. You know I mean my optic nerves were crushed by the swelling in my
brain. Right. I mean absolutely one hundred percent
totally crushed. Arm. And you know I mean
yeah maybe nowadays if if we ever get with the program and really start you know investing in
stem cell research maybe they could regenerate optic nerves but
you know that I think that's going to down the line past certainly
past my prime you know even if I'm eighty I don't know that I'd go for surgery
at that point my life you know. I've probably I don't know but
anyway but I remember the social worker
.
Talking to me in the hospital. And I said something about. Well I'm
just going to get out. I'm going to get surgery and you know I have my eyes you know I'll
just get eye transplants. And she said I don't think
. They can do that. And I said What are you talking about. They do it all the time and
she said but that's not a part of your ONLY that's you have been affected
. And on. And that's that's when I first
realized that my eyesight was not coming back
.
And that that was really really depressing really depressing.
But you know again you know a fifteen year old kid is pretty resilient.
And you know I and I think I am I think Mido once Rick
No I'm very reserved yet you know and I just said screw it you
know I'll just go on but I remember one week in my head
thinking if I'm not if I can see by the time I graduate high school I'll just kill
myself.
But I never really.
You know that was like my little plan. But I never really thought I would
do it you know.
But some point if there are I mean what kind of help did you get to go back to
school or OK So well in school.
Yes So what they did was. You know well my
because I got sick in May right. Oh I done well enough in
all my classes that they passed me from freshman year only
one class ironically typing decided she was going to pass and you can be an incomplete
whatever it didn't I knew how to type spotty really care because I had learned to type before I
even took that class and we took the class because it's going to be easy to pass it on because of my mother an
I.B.M. Selectric at home and I learned to type on that anyway
so I was really the sickest. In May June and July. Right.
So why organist I was pretty I was you know pretty much getting better
. So the school started sending.
Tutors in September. On my French. They sent a French tutor
teacher you know an english. Teacher.
I don't remember if they sent a math teacher I feel like there were three
teachers. And I remember the two the
French or the English. But I don't remember if there was a third
and it's kind of curious that it was French and not like history but now
.
But anyway so I don't know and maybe they did other work with me like maybe I think it was like to
get in on this with fear that through to my favorite high school English teachers
either one of those I don't win again and came to my house as a tutor
later but anyway.
You don't like history work with me too you know they say they were there to read to me and they asked me questions and
like only answers and things so that they did but what they also
did was with Montel. You know
they set up like a walkie talkie type system. At my school
and in my hospital room so that. They would just carry
this device from class to class wherever it was going to the next
class I could bring in and then I would listen in to my
classes that way or it was really great. Maybe that's the only reason they sent the
English or the French because those were the two I think they did send a math teacher or maybe I just
didn't take mass that first semester because I remember pretty
clearly from my high school they had two trucks college prep and
and what they call business and if you were in college prep all of you
definitely take four years of English four years of.
Health I think you have to take four years two years maybe three of history
you had to take at least two years of you know two math
classes. Maybe three.
And on and then a bunch of different electives and a language you had to take language
so well. So I'm pretty sure they did send a math tutor.
So anyway but some of the students of my classes and then you know
I would blame the teachers that came you know in the afternoons would I guess give me the
assignments. There's a lot of pressure over every one of my own.
English classes classes like we see so funny that we get like a spelling test in a
vocabulary test and in sophomore year but I guess we did and I
remember I will make do with a test over the you know for one thing
but you know luckily I got one hundred percent every time so you know I mean
you know I feel embarrassed you know. But
. I knew it wasn't meant to be a mean thing like because I remember saying you've got
it right in front because you've got a mind like a steel trap. It's amazing you know.
But then so that's why I think I was able to go back to school in January you know
when I got out of the hospital I went right back after the Christmas break on
there was a little push back to school I was nervous about
having a totally blind student. I was connected with the New
Jersey commission for the blind. And they were great about it they just
said no this is her choice she wants to come back to school. We will help you will
help put together with and you know it without really too much
pushback and it was a little bit but the school just said OK. And how do we do
this you know and they got the woman she was an older woman and
she's probably forty and I was sixteen.
But another woman who had worked with blind since I guess she was probably a T.V. Ali
and she helped with you know like like for my geometry
class and all she helped make little manipulable stuff like
Fiola and. And then we had just like a student teacher who
was like for starters I would have like study hall periods you know I would go into.
You know they are much like those in the library and
all. We were just you know she would read me my silence that I would dictate you know my
answers this is all pre computers people there was
. No computers I guess they were but not you know
that is seventy eight seventy nine. Not really you know I think he left the
library got computers that year I graduate in ninety eight
. But anyway and I was not a
Braille reader. I. Tried at first I resisted
completely I didn't want to read that shit.
You know that's my attitude towards it was you know I read visually I don't want to read
that you know but my my commission councillor was actually
really clever and she said well we could we could bring all these Patti Smith poems you
know.
It was really cool of her because though they were kind of risk you know they were a little dirty some of them and
there was some language you know but I guess you could have my mother in my Or if I was reading them then you
know it was fine.
So I just you know because of the paralysis and the residual
neuropathy I just was never able to really pick it up and subsequent to
that I've tried several times to learn to read Braille and I've just not had any
luck. I had a little bit of luck in the ninety's I was really dedicated to it
and I was doing all right but. You know and I actually you know I
memorized the code on Grade one Grade two I I
did learn but then after a while I because I didn't read it I you know lost that
but. So I was able you know back in the day to use a breadman
speak to write in Braille. So that really reinforced
I'm learning the code but it was just never going to be an efficient way for me
to actually read. So everything you know I did was always
either on tape. Or. On. You know I don't
. You know I would go. Dictate and someone else would
transcribe.
All I remember even so there's another student I remember in senior English class there
was an essay I don't want this kid Jared either Mr finished early or
he wasn't taking the test that day because I remember the teacher saying Jerry will you go talk to the librarian
just write her essay and you know we did it and
. It was about Brave New World I remember very clearly because I remember using the word quasi
religious and it was like a good back in the day when when I school
students seniors knew how to write you know.
But. So that you know.
I forget what you want is how the school dealt with it and more. So yeah I mean and they
even formed a little community of five a great
committee or five or four committee and I was on it and a woman who had
a developmentally delayed son and another guy. Who
I guess he was a parent and he was he used a wheelchair and we would have little meetings
about how the school could be more and the principal the assistant principal and
talk about how the school could be more accessible and better it was.
It's amazing I you know I've reconnected with so many people I went to high school with now
on Facebook and on and I did go to my twenty year class
reunion back in two thousand I did not go
to the thirty year one I wish I had.
There were circumstances that made it impossible for me to go on. But
I axed some of the women that you know I went to school with have
said to me Don I. Have used you as an
inspiration to you know my kids when my kids would I have one
friend whose daughter is very very very sick when she was in seventh grade with
I don't know if it's congestive like cystic fibrosis or so
she just retains fluids in her lungs and gets very very sick and
this friend of mine said you know I told my daughter about you and how you are an example of someone who
could really perseverant that she could do it too
. And and you know look for most of us we don't like to hear that you know we feel like oh that's
just you know. I'll smoke or whatever but.
If you know in a way. I feel like if I was able to
give people. Something that they could use in
raising their kids to. Talk about you know how you
. You know you personally are and you and you work through hard
times because you know. No matter how you want to cut it you're getting
that sick and being you know at fifteen and having to deal with that
that is a hard time having now right my blindness is you know something I'm
comfortable with I'm not happy about it you know I wish I didn't you know
happen in some ways in some ways I also see it as a
real and incredibly invaluable experience because. I
think.
What I always think about being blind and I don't know exactly how to
articulate it but I've said to people that until you experience
it. You really have no clue what it is. Like it's
not what I would have thought. Being blind would be. You know I don't know
what I thought. I guess you know the experience of putting a blindfold
on. Because I remember we did that in like eighth graders
something put blindfolds on had people walk us around like it was a
class activity that we did. For some reason.
And feeling scared in this world and all the things that a sighted person who just
suddenly became blindfolded would feel.
Pain. And I guess you know that's what you'd think of that's what
we're always told sighted people think when they look at us they think oh my god how did how
do you. How do you get up and walk across the room and how do you.
Because they think about well if I put a blindfold on that I would be scared and
disoriented and fears and they you know think about the fact that we've learned you know
techniques and you know we've been trained or figure things out on our own
. So. But
you know I think. It's. I don't
you know. Even though I'm totally blind and really have.
No light perception like I think I have light perception because when I turn on
the light I think I should see the light but I recently had left a
job earlier this year and I opened a case with the New York state commission for
the Blind in order to go through the entrepreneurship program start my own business
. So of course I guess it was the commission has sent me to an
eye doctor you know to verify that I'm blind.
And I mean he was shining the light usually coming when you see the light and you know he said
that. Would be like.
Now you know like I thought you said you had life.
It's not a good idea I guess I don't you know but
but it's a much more you know dynamic world then
I think sighted people imagine it to me you know
.
And that makes sense of course because right it's you know it's not again not that your other senses
become heightened answers that you tune into them more or you use them
you know or you you real you know you hear oh you're just made more aware
. Of. Things but then you know especially if you've had a vision I
can't speak to what it must be like if you haven't had vision but if
I know that. I think.
I have a visual imagery in my head at all times you know and
what's interesting about it for me is that it's. A
visual. Like it's not a realistic visual perception. Or
perspective. I guess it's not as if. I
only picture you and the things on the table at
my hands which are on the table.
It's like I sort of picture everything in this three hundred sixty including
myself you know and I think it's your time you know to be able to
see myself so. So in a sense it's almost a richer
visual. World. Then. Than
actual vision. So I don't know I mean
not really because. You know I think a visual memories I think of how
stunning.
Vision is. You know something. To be.
Real. I.
Mean I have just memories of things like like walking home from school.
And then walking up the driveway and we had a dogwood tree at the side of the
house and just looking at the dog wood in the grass it was a spring day and the blue
sky and just picture perfect days and just just how pretty
everything was you know.
And things like that and you know.
So I you know of course. I know that a real you know visual
perception is you know stunningly intense
in a way that Mommy. Made up. Or imagined. Right.
Perception is not.
What it is and the interesting thing there too is that I sort of dampen it because the
perception I don't picture it as vividly as I would
if I were trying to conjure like an image of. What this
must actually look like. Right. Like I sort of put a little
grayish. Black and white kind of tone over it because.
I think somewhere it might. Be OK.
So we break you know like SR does not equate you know
real or whatever you know it's. So when did you come to New York
City. I came to New York in one thousand nine hundred eighty eight
for college I knew I wanted to go I always knew I wanted to live in New York as I
said I wrote twenty eight miles west of New York.
We used to come in here all the time especially during senior year we could see Lou Reed concerts
and Paddy concerts and G.B. and you don't remember
ninety days of the legal drinking age was eighteen and we were all eighteen you know
. So I always knew him from the time I was a little girl but I like
to live in New York. So. I do.
What I want to apply to Columbia and more you know what it
was like the only two schools I know even know what their high school was in New York
City right. But. Somehow I didn't end up applying to
Columbia I only applied to N.Y.U. I applied for early admissions. I think
it was because my mother was like no you shouldn't live downtown.
Blah blah blah you know. Because the village at that time was really a
totally different place it was much more much more. I
mean I remember going to parties.
In you know at every party every D. and fourteenth
Street and we went in a group of like eight people there
was no way you could go. Over to Alphabet City. Of
by yourself.
I remember being at parties and people showing up and having a mug with you know
broken skin you know like my friend Michael Board and I were
held and knifepoint by a train Z. And you
know Kansas fried chicken on fourteenth Street and Second Avenue mind
you. Yeah. And nobody helped people walk in and see what was going
on and just walk right out.
But eventually Michael got the knife away from him and. Threw it over the counter.
Call the cops. And we got to leave. But
. But yes I applied for early admissions
on me.
And I got accepted and.
So that's where I knew I was coming and my mom came in and we we decided over the
summer we drive in and try to meet with like I'm really just I was going to register for
you not pick the classes I wanted and we would come in and meet with whatever
professors we couldn't see if we could get the syllabi and dorm reading
lists and see order from recordings for the blind or what
. We. Were professors
I think for classes maybe only three I think the first semester I took only
three. Now I think that for I think I dropped one but the first
professor there was going to be a change in that Professor because
there was a big scandal he was called Dr quit looting was an anthropology professor and he was
making clear limits at N.Y.U. and he got fired. So the
woman that was going to be teaching the class was like anthropology You know one of those surveyed
classes. She was like on a date in believes or something
you know and. Couldn't you know she they she hadn't made it her syllabus yet.
So the syllabus that the other guy even you know I thought
she would probably use the same texts. So we ordered
whatever books we could and those we couldn't we bought.
And my mom and her friends recorded them for me so that when I started for
school I would be able to I would have all my books. And
unfortunately it turned out that. That anthropology
class the woman I mean was Linda Bass be a Associate
Professor but she didn't she used one of the four
texts she used one or two but then she was using to others
. And I was scrambling to get somebody to record them but it was
and she was really good this professor. She was so willing to work with me. She was like you know
maybe I can we can do it like a modified almost independent study and I can work with you
want the other books that you recorded.
I mean it was really you know in some ways I feel like I've had this charmed life I mean
this of course in the in the context of the fact that
I mean I don't want my life I wanted to be a filmmaker I wanted to I
love movies I like
. That's how I met my friend Michael Cera. That's how you know I first got to
really be friends we just both loved movies. He actually is a
filmmaker and a film critic now but you know I wanted to do the same thing I
wanted to write movies and to write them and maybe do some acting.
So when I lost my sight Of course I. I just thought well I'll just write you know I
love writing I'll be I'll be a journalist or all be right or you know
. So that's what I planned to do at it. Go.
On.
And I took. The first journalism course I took went really well and the professor was
very nice and helpful. But and even the
second one I saw was a woman professor and she was pretty good the
first one it was for something like media in America or something like that or the history
of media and it was really interesting because many people don't realize is how much
crime journalists and writers and lawyers write were responsible for the
revolution right the American Revolution so it's all tied up in
American history. The Stamp Act. They want to.
Put a. Tax on paper you know that was not a smart thing to do is piss off
journalists right. So but anyway.
And then the second was called reporting one o one and I was mostly just
writing and learning and write a story. Third course I took that I
didn't know when media in America is like and that. Was with the. Department
chair arm chair and that man. Was a complete
. Asshole he could not be used to Portman. He. Flat
out told me you cannot be. A journal you cannot be a
reporter because you're blind. Purely. Right and it was
ninety or ninety one I think it was probably by might or.
Might have been my first freshman year I think was my sophomore year. And on.
And you know I was a kid and what did I know. And there was no way D.N.A. I mean
yes that was the Rehab Act.
You know. And I was even on the fog of war we have a committee at N.Y.U.
. But. I may not have been at that point I might have joined like in
my. Junior years.
But I just. I just didn't even think to fight it
wasn't right. I knew he was wrong. I knew what he was saying was false
.
But. I couldn't easily. There was no
technology and wasn't Braille reader. I didn't have the
tools.
Never mind the actual logistical tools I didn't have the emotional advocacy tools to
know what how to fight this is the chair of the department. You know
if I could remember his name I'd say.
You know something I think that I think I remember his name but I
know I don't exactly. So.
I gave up the dream of being a journalist I just said. OK. I'll do
something else. And there's something else I chose was
French. And it was because it was I mean I had studied
French from the time I was in sixth grade through senior year in high school
. And when I got to N.Y.U. intro to French
was a five day week with a mandatory language lab. And it was six
credits and I thought that's an easy game.
Since I was twelve years old I'm going to take into a French and I did it and
then. I took. You know whatever the next one was and
it was like elementary French an intermediate French and and then my friends Patty and Jenny
and I went to Pat went to Paris and to the south of France one summer I think it was the
summer of one thousand nine hundred one or a Jew. But when I had taken
more French classes. So that's when I said screw it you know I know you has
so has it and what your broad program the French Department is nice they like
me and I'll go study French you know because that's the way nineteen year
olds think don't think about your career.
And but you know in the back of my mind I've never
.
Healed fully from being told I couldn't be a teacher as I
wish I had fought it I wish I had known how to fight it
but then you know. When you're blind when you're home and when you're a lesbian when
you're you know you're you're fighting all your life and so
. Who you know who wants to fight everything all the time but
I think that would have been a real fight a real fight and
I think even just going to do the N.Y.U. broad program was a little bit of a struggle because
you know the department was a little freaked out by it.
Luckily I had an advocate at home and I do remember her name is Kathy teller ecologies I don't
think she's learned what you anymore but she just she was like this one of those or she just
like you know people are saying maybe she shouldn't go to the and my brother and she just
kept like putting in my paperwork and help me.
And she was great and she was just terrific and. You
know and then I did I mean it was that. So yeah I did sort of regret
not having become a journalist but by the same token I mean. I can't
believe I got to live for a year in Paris and all of what that
meant that I mean my French is way Rusty now and you know I have a
master's degree in French. I wrote my master's thesis in French you know
. I was completely fluent in French but you know that's. One
thousand nine hundred seventy nine you know really no one is around the last time I was really speaking French
so my French is pretty rusty but.
And what an amazing experience. And. I met some of
my dearest friends people I'm still friends with from from the United States as well
as from you know on other parts of Europe. On what I was at.
N.Y.U. and. Paris and you know I did so well that N.Y.U.
offered me a fellowship to stay on and do my master's degree. And they
paid for. You know they paid for my entire solution. And I have a
. You know a job at the university and I got paid my you know fellowship
money. On and it was at that point that I really started becoming more interested
in. I don't linguistics as opposed to just French I was
studying Italian when I was in France. I learned Italian and then I was
auditing in German classes and I got this German teacher while I was here
. So.
Back at N.Y.U. and I was applying you know to Ph D.
programs and I'm going to sound like you again because when I applied
to Yale I applied to Penn and I applied to N.Y.U. for my Ph
D. and I have done my research fellowship when I was a
Master's candidate at N.Y.U. in French at that point I was really
starting to be more interested in linguistics then just
language.
And. I really was interested in you know the sort of
computer application of linguistics synthetic speech and voice
recognition and the woman who was the graduate chair at the
linguistics department. On. Dr who recalled Maida
she was working on very early speech language and
. Constant battle sequences you know developing synthetic
speech with something called the class synthesizer which was invented by Dennis glad that later became
the deck talk arm. And I think I asked the
Department of French department if I could do my fellowship. Work in the
department listings and they said yes that wouldn't be a problem. I did I think I
did one half of the research fellowship in French Department and the other half it was
Dick's and.
So I didn't really frankly want to stay you don't want you for my Ph D. I
wanted to go to an Ivy League school and I wanted to leave and well
you know even though I loved it you know after a certain point you're like I need to get a degree from a
different school because it's too incestuous. It's you know it
but I did apply when I applied to Yale and Penn I also applied to everyone you know
because. It was like my backup plan and why he was
not going to reject me because you know I had successfully done my
bachelor's and master's degree there and I had worked with the linguistics
department on a successful fellowship and. So on.
But of course reared its ugly head again and then the guy who was the
chair of the department I can't remember his name anymore either so you have blocked out the ones that were really
horrible. He was not.
He was not. Wanting me to be in his department and I remember I
was in his office for the one of the most tense
meetings. You know. And at one point it was long it
was two three hours long. And at one point I just said something because I was smarter
at that point right I was twenty six or twenty seven. We
still were a few years away from the day but I said.
You were not saying to me Dr whatever that you don't want me in your
department because I'm blind or you know. And he said no I'm not saying that I said
good so I'll expect my letter of acceptance you.
Know and I did get accepted and of course but I also got accepted
and I was much happier to go there. Oh University of Pennsylvania at a
much. You know what I thought was a much better mystics are not that that was
not their enemies was bad but you know William noble
giant of. Linguistics is I was the chair of
the department. And he said when I worked under for my research fellowships that a
couple of years I was there and on. Every front and frankly
to Noam Chomsky has degrees from
. Penn is Ph D. in linguistics even though most people
associate him with an oddity or Harvard but he studied under so
I actually had some of the same professors. They were very very old.
I did I had some of the tops of these professors when I was at and I
toured I toured that program and.
Almost anything. Up until my recent divorce actually
the only regret I had. Deep regret I had in life
was that I did not finish my Ph D. in physics that I walked away
from a full fellowship. Here. And
. But you know then I would have been a college professor which is what I
sort of wish I was but a part and then again going back to
that story that I tell myself. Right. I did it because
I saw people graduating with Ph D.'s from you know what was
arguably the best sociolinguistics department in the world. And they were
lucky to get jobs and you know cancers and I want to come back to New York I
was I was in a relationship that it ended it ended very badly.
She was cheating on me. I I was you know it was horrible I've also been
betrayed and I just wanted to come back to New York I didn't
. Actually at first I fled to Berkeley. I decided on. Or
put California for a summer. But I mean like if there was two
. As as as Mike Michael Cera came with me to help me sort of get situated
he said there's way too much modulus and that's what he
said to me I think I'm the only man I've seen in a necktie in the
area but it just wasn't for me I mean they were very nice and I I think and
I think they had a whole sort of west coast school of linguistics out at Stanford and
Berkeley and all but it just wasn't for me it wasn't for me the lifestyle or
whatever and I want for New York every time I've ever lived anywhere
but is now just heating this town these days. I you know I
always want to come back to New York I can't imagine. Where else I
could live you know.
When you talked about influences in your life like the influence
of the feminist movement and. I'm wondering
how that played out. In the experiences you
had experiences with how people reacted to your
disability and the things that didn't work out because of that. Yeah
.
Well I think you know it's about that that you with a passion. It's interesting you
know. I mean I was. I
feel like I was born. A fence. Or porch. Or that's my water
bottle going to be a feminist just the time growing up
at the time that I did as I mentioned earlier. You know
Ms Magazine and you know there's a there's a a documentary it
opens this Friday called She's beautiful when she's angry and it's all about
that early you know feminist movement and I can't wait to see it
because. You know. I did I saw some clips
of it and I was like wow I remember these things I mean I was so young but I remember it.
Only.
Recently. A few years ago a colleague of mine was honored at something
called a New York Women's Agenda. It's a nonprofit you know sort of a consortium
of non-profit agencies and you're if you're a member
Agency which the agency I was working for at the time was you could nominate
you know one of your female employees from the author and so there's all these women that are
. But then there are celebrities that are ordered to and here and I went
to it and I don't because I really love this colleague but
I mean I wouldn't normally got breakfast at seven o'clock in the morning you know down in
Paris you know not. OK.
So but Jane Fonda was being honored. She was the
celebrity being honored and she was she was
being introduced and that honor was being presented by Gloria Steinem
and you know I mentioned before I love theater I go to a lot of
theater and calm and I think some theater is just extraordinary
.
But it was very rare for me personally to stand up at the
end of a show.
It has to be exceptional and that's not only because I think that's a really
special honor and I know people in nowadays people jump up the minute the curtain falls because you know I
mean if you paid three hundred dollars to see a show for what you know you're going to get a
standing ovation.
But when I when Gloria Steinem came out on that stage I
leapt to my feet and started applauding I just couldn't believe I was
in the same room of course I know my colleague who was sitting behind her all
said she just she said Jane Fonda looked a little frail and in fact she got she
got really cold at one point and he had to come bring her sweater.
But she said Gloria Steinem was like extraordinary cherub like these these really
are.
A purple velvet like bell bottom pants and this big red get a
belt and you know she was unbelievable. But
. I mean in a way it's
really funny that I was so influenced by
feminism in a way because you know like I said my mom was this
kind of stay at home mom. And even if she was really a strong independent
woman. You know she wasn't
a super feminist in any way but it was just part of the ethos you
know. Ms Magazine free to be you and me Gloria Steinem the expos of Playboy
the you know the.
I mean you know why don't you be here and one day at a time you
know and Romano a single mom raising her kids and you know
I was telling you the other day you know I I remember going to sleep over a
girlfriend's house when I was a girl I was like twelve and I was wearing a T.
shirt that said I think it's a glorious time code is you know a woman without a
man is like a fish without a bicycle. And on the girl's
father and brother just laid into me and started arguing
with me and you know and I just there was this twelve year old like totally
standing up for my ferret is believes you know what we're doing that you know equal pay for
equal work and you know global and it's
just.
I. Wonder if. Like it was
part of you know we somehow. Knowing that I was a lesbian
but not really knowing. What you know I
mean kids then more were much more naive in that way I
mean I think in a way we were more politically savvy than than kids maybe are
today. But. You know.
Being gay in the seventy's and suburban New Jersey was not something you would
have discussed or wished or wanted to. You know so but I mean certainly by the time I
was in high school I knew it you know I knew I was a lesbian but you know I
didn't really as I mentioned earlier that I was I came to N.Y.U.
. And I started seeing people like me you know. But as far as sort of the
feminism and the disability. I don't know
when I. I feel like being a feminist
.
Need. It more OK with being a
lesbian and that being blind even though frankly back in
the day anyone who knows the history of the women's movement knows there was there was a
real push to marginalize lesbians. They didn't
because the straight women didn't want everybody to think that feminists were
lesbians officer and so and apparently that is very well
documented in this this. This documentary that was on the net
but in any case I think being blind we were
able to be out as a lesbian because being blind was
something you know I'm totally blind I use a guide dog. I've used to guide dog
for thirty six years. I'm curious to
know I mean people I mean because.
You don't want my. Blindness as a result of optic nerve damage.
People are often somewhat confused because you know I don't have anything clearly
strange you know wrong with my eyes or you know and I can look and of course having outside
I can look at people and blah blah blah. But but there is no
mistaking me as a blind person unless you you. Know. So
being completely out and of being able to pass as not blind I
think sort of made it OK for me to be a lesbian too because I was like What the
hell you know it's just one more thing that like you know puts me apart
from the norm and. And being a
feminist being a woman. Feminist woman was just
something I was always proud of. I mean by. By the
time.
I was thirteen or fourteen and my parents split up and I saw where my life was going
right and we moved from the Tony Hills of Washington down back to
you know North Plains which don't get me wrong I love North Plainfield I love my hometown but it was
you know it's it's not fancy I was all immigrants you know
Italian remembers what you say to me but she wasn't till she had gone to
college in Michigan that she realized OK Two thirds of the world is an Italian you know but you
. Know I knew by the time I was in
early teens I was going to have to. Go to college and get a job and I was
probably before I lost my SO sight I figured I was going to have to work in order to
go to college because there was nobody I was going to be able to pay for me to go to
college. In fact my brother Stephen did you move to California establish
residency and work full time he worked from seven in the morning to three in the afternoon. Then he drove
two hours and went to school from six o'clock in the evening till ten o'clock in the evening you know to get
his college degree. I lucked out I got
my god the commission for the blind to help me so. And I got to
go to a private college my brother went to a community college. Well you know OK
California State College not so much music out but
you know. I don't I don't know or
.
I don't know it's an interesting question that interplay between feminism
and disability.
And certainly I don't think maybe you need me to have more of
a predilection for. Advocacy although I
don't think of myself as a really. Strong.
Like that. I don't see as my major role in life. As an advocate
. I certainly feel that I'm a champion of.
People. Whose rights are often squashed. But that's
not just disabled people. For me that's you know
.
Black and brown people and women and Arabs and
Jews and all kinds of people that in other are being you know women
being you know like getting disenfranchised wherever they are in
the world. But. But you know I mean
and you know curiously I. Have not always necessarily
advocated very strongly for for myself.
I have at times. But many times I haven't. So
.
I don't know. Do you think you see if your experiences of
my resume in France or if there was anything different there.
There was. Possibly a little
more. Of.
A. Paternalistic type. We have to take
care of you. But it was not.
All for.
In that way. There are organizations
. You know that they you know helped me with
. There were books I could get even in English you know or recorded
books you know for pleasure of reading their work. There were volunteer
organizations that help to support me because when you you know
go there for the end where you program you can take your not only are you
registered with N.Y.U. which has its own facility and you take two classes a
semester at N.Y.U. or in Paris. But you could you are registered with the
nineteen colleges of the Sorbonne University in Paris. So you could take
courses anywhere and I took. Courses at one of the schools that
really specialized like intellect and linguistics and language
so you know.
And it's my god. Paris is not an easy city to navigate I mean it
was built in seven ninety nine or something like
thirty I don't know what it's been there since you know easily the the eighth century you
know.
And or ninth century and.
There are streets that are just tiny you know and and
it's like lower Manhattan you know like way lower Manhattan where they just curl around and
you keep walking and then you're over so you're on a different street and you know you have no idea how that happened
and people just park on the side walk. What I will tell you is the
French tour dogs they out was never an issue
. Bringing my guide dog anywhere because all dogs went every few
hours in restaurants you know they just
adore dogs. So.
On. So that was you know. Find
you know the woman who sort of ran the and where you program you know
from an administrative standpoint of faculty standpoint was very nice
but she was very worried about me. I think again she was somewhat
older woman and I think she felt I was her responsibility and
at some point. You know when I first went to the
N.Y.U. program even though I was still kind of a punk like I
think I kind of like children down a little for Paris.
I kind of went back to you know just Khaki is and
tops and I think I even sometimes wear skirts I think that that was an
experiment I had for a little while I was like right before I left for presents like I'm going to wear skirts
and I put out some scripts for the night. I like just couldn't deal with it I was like I feel like a drag
I cannot do this you know but I have this notion that I was going to do
that I was going to wear skirts pond was over you know even though you
know we all still liked our own music and it was over it was over by nine hundred eighty one eighty
two.
Patti had retired in one thousand nine hundred eighty two and we came back after Frederic husband died
and she did make more money but I think she did because she's doing great now but
anyway all right. So. But at
some point in the middle of the academic year at N.Y.U. abroad
like I did I went super punk like super punk and
that's when I first started cutting my hair super super super
short and bleaching it. I mean at that time my hair was. Very
dark brown and so I would strip it out. White.
Platinum Blonde and then that guy this guy had
to my hair in Paris he was amazing he was like an artist and he would shave all kinds of
weird designs and do it and then he'd color them in different colors. There's this
photograph of me in this French journalist Yuri sitting on this
. Bench outside of the foyer where I lived and it's my
friend Ethan took it from behind and my hair and it just looks like it's like
a lightning bolt.
In in this blinded you know.
Yes that is then what color didn't read in purple and blue
and I mean it was just extraordinary. It would take it to when I was dedicated man it took
like six hours to get get my hair done and because it was so short I
had ever done often.
But some and I started my friend a friend of mine came to visit me on
. Christmas time. There was a Christmas time
and. That's when I think that's when we first cut my hair that was
. It she just cut it you know and then I found to be a star doing it
for real. But. And then she took me shopping she's like don't you
look you you know you're not you anymore you take shopping get out these corduroys get out you know
as you want me you know like. Skinny like black jeans and boots and leather
jacket and blah blah blah. You know gave me a whole new make over
.
And so I just became a punk again like super punk and that freaked out a
lot of the faculty and people I was dealing with
. So that was kind of hard. And also some of the all
the other volunteers that would have scored me places like they were not cool with it you know
but you know. That was part of being a punk right was the
whole rebellion piece of it. That's rock N roll lifestyle slow
and it was at that point in my life that I was really starting. To
realize. That I was a lesbian and that I was going to be a
lesbian and that nothing was going to make me. Go
back. You know. To not. And
. You know what it was after that when I came back from
Paris in eighty five you know I real I had my first real
significant relationship with a woman.
And then the rest is history. Never entered it never
you know went back. Home. And that until
of course and I know I was in two thousand and one well in two
thousand the very end of two thousand. And we met
online back when I was dating services were actually free. I'm
amazed that people paid for that now.
But yeah it was I think it was a site called Friend Finder.
That's what I'm almost positive it was called but it's if it was it's long gone. Because
I tried to find it once before. You know. So
and I mean of what I liked especially
about meeting women for whom the services the dating
services online was like you could tell first of all some of them had amazing
algorithms and really matched you very very well. Like they were just you know send you
a note saying so and so just you know fill out a profile in matching here and you could pick the
parameters of what was important you age and you could pick age range you could pick whether
they should have a graduate degree you could pick what kind of things they like to do you know.
But what was amazing to me because I had a few. Experience is
where I met someone we talked on the phone it didn't work out or I had a brief
affair or someone that I met online but
. You could like what you I mean for me and Elizabeth
. We would write his own letter. It's like real we
write to each other you know and we did that for weeks and weeks before we met
and we were great clever intelligent you know things and I would
you know so that was that was an amazing way to get to know whether
you thought somebody would be right for you because you know if I wrote something like
this you would start with just a hello I saw your profile looks like we might have some
things in common and if they were like you know you want to get together and they're like oh.
I want to know who you are before.
You know because there was no you know that the idea of when do you tell that you are
disabled you know and what friend front fighter there actually was
a box you could check off that you were disabled and you could say what you had hearing loss
but it was true and I. And I had seen other sites where you could do that
too and I never did it. I just left a black book with this time I said screw
it I'm doing it because I'm sick of deciding when is an appropriate time
to tell the person because if they'd send you a picture you know what. I
. Do. I don't want to show anybody your picture and I don't want to tell you that I can't see your
picture. And so you know you wouldn't know what to say you know.
So.
And it was funny with a friend finder you could check the box but it was like really
down it was like so far down on the profile that I thought you know what I've got a lot
of people want to get there you know. Because I knew I would be looking for people's
profiles like after the first few things you know. You're like now
we're you know this looks interesting and he stopped reading.
So when I was first writing there was a point at which she had said she
was very active. She was a martial artist and she
was a fencer. No wonder you know so you know
she said that she had twisted her ankle and was having a really
hard time going up and down the subway stairs. And I responded I
said something like yes all you temporarily able
bodied folks should learn now and again what
. What it's like to be disabled. As she wrote back and she
said I you know I don't know if it was very terse but
put me in my place basically saying I have a disability. She had a traumatic brain
injury because of a car wreck and of course you know that's that's just very
hard disability to live with because it's invisible to most people and you know it's
very hard to understand what it means because it's not the same for
everybody there are you know and and it changes you know how some day he is
you know she would be really sharp and on point and other days she'd be extremely
fatigued or you know were confused. So
. That's when I said well you know and I did go back and I said you
know I'm really sorry I mean you know.
I didn't know she had put it in her profile I think I would have seen it yet but
maybe not. And was funny about her profile because when I was looking through
I was notified that she had logged in you know that she had signed up and I went and looked at her
profile and I thought this looks like a really interesting person but then what are your
hobbies.
All our hobbies were like running skating
in martial arts. This that she was a huge science
fiction fan I was like boy this is just not you know this is not me I'm not in the
active lifestyle gal I like you know sit around a tree you can watch
it you know and so on and I'm
very social but you know that I like to go out for meals and I like to you know.
Clearly I like to talk I'm talking for hours here but so
.
But anyway I went a couple days later I went back to her profile and I
just said I got a right to her because something you know and she
later told me that she also had gotten notice of my profile but
it was like before Thanksgiving and her friends in Texas and she was leaving Texas so she
didn't get a chance to write. But but anyway. So we
ended up writing and writing and writing and and then eventually on January twenty second we
had our first date and we were twenty second two thousand and one.
And. It was and I knew from that minute that
this was the person I wanted to spend the rest of my life with and you know sadly for
me I can still feel that way. You know we've been separated
for a little over a year on it was not my decision to
separate. Although I realize that there were problems in
the relationship. Of course to first blame myself for all the problems because I think you
know that's. That's what you do when you know when when something goes wrong that you don't want to
go wrong.
But then. You know what I've come to realize
. Looking back at the thirteen years we were together all
over missed all the problems that existed you know in a
marriage you know that that both people contributed
. But.
But you know we were we were really really happy for a very long time you know when we
we moved in she she moved into my partner's funny you know met online and I
live on West twenty second Street and she was living on West sixteenth
Street. So you know we were like six blocks away from each other and never seen
each other. Or. You know run into each other in fact the first
night that I asked her if she wanted to go out of the place I picked to go
for dinner was at the corner of sixteenth Street and Eighth Avenue
and I said Do you know where the Chelsea grill is played is that you've got this smile
because it was on her walk. So. But you
know. That. You know we
. It's hard I mean we were together through nine eleven
through the death of my mother through. You know happy times. Good
job bad job. Loss of her jobs. Death
of two beloved seeing eye dogs. You know we got married
in two thousand and eleven August of two thousand Aug eighth two thousand and
eleven when same sex marriage was legalized. When we got married you
know.
So you know unfortunately that also meant we ended up having to get divorced which it
is amazingly difficult to get a divorce in a reasonably simple to get
. Married. She filed for
divorce and you know the pause was something
like you know retrievable breakdown of the relationship and then
you know because she was the one filing she had to like talk to the attorneys and you know and she
didn't want any alimony or any you know she just wanted out
. But. You know she was telling me that they were asking for things
like well you know you can't just have one fight and then you know want to divorce.
That's No one. When he could have won women together and we're going to marriage license I
mean there's no it's so easy to get married and it is it
took forever to get the divorce
. Isn't that ironic in for me that this was you know it's so easy to get married.
Yeah but you know this is it's incredibly easy to just go there you have to go ahead of time the
day before a couple days before to get I don't know what all this shit is about blood tests at all I think
it like this I think there was an old times when V.D. tests you know
but.
We just you know went to the they call it the marriage center everybody calls it things at
city hall but it's not it's actually them it's called the marriage Center it's a new new facility was
built not so many years ago.
And you know you get a number and then you go and you know when your number is
called you you get.
Some files and papers and they give you.
It's going to give you something and then you come back. The next day or a couple days later
and you bring a witness and you get married
. But song but it's an amazing place because especially in New York
because for one thing this was you know there were there were a lot of like military personnel
in like four regalia because you know they were going to get married when they when they're home you know
wimmin sloper I don't get you know there were two
women and four bridal gowns you know a lesbian couple there were you know men
in you know in jeans and T. shirts getting married there was you know there were like
folks from other cultures and countries in like you know on you know their sort of
classic you know like African go or to work or you know Middle
Eastern or so and you know there's been you know lives within our you know we have like
matching T. shirts and look at what other magic T. shirts for
our bridal party and we all were a bunch of kitschy rainbow stuff you know we had
like rainbow bracelets and rings. You know but it's really an amazing place
that that someone should do a documentary about because.
It's it's really quite amazing that that was so it's funny that I was
there a very very happy time I never thought of
getting married. Do you know I mean I was so happy when it started being
legalized all over the country and especially in New York.
And of course we would get married. I mean but. I never thought it would be
that happy.
You know something I felt like such a citizen
you know like I have rights the end of it you know in a way I mean
I you know I've talked to you about this it's not.
You know being a lesbian in New York in the twenty first century is not that hard
and you know you don't have to be closeted and you know we
had through my my job we had health insurance we were
domestic partners and we had you know health insurance she was covered by my health
insurance we had you know any time I had been hospitalized several times with
broken bones and various things during our relationship and no one
ever. Had her in to see me or you know and nothing you
know we.
Well we've really got you know logistically from the marriage
was the ability to file federal income tax jointly
and let me tell you something. My refund before we were
married when I would file with her just as a dependent and I would file
head of household. I would get like fourteen hundred dollars
back from the feds. Once I started being able to file
jointly. Married find. My. My refund like
. Almost tripled. I was getting like thirty thirty eight hundred dollars It was
unbelievable.
It was I was like Man these headers.
Now this is the shit right and it's also because of like things like if you're
married and you you know one partner dies one spouse dies
the other one gets to inherit everything without having to pay
tax. Whereas if you were domestic partners you know that's not true.
So it really was a financial thing but that's not what we'd be happy. It was I was just so happy to
be an Elizabeth it was happy too. We were very happy and then you know
sadly things whereof to the agency where I was working at the
time it was right around then that things started going badly for me I started
arguing with upper management and feeling like there was a deep philosophical
split in how I felt about the services we worked I was a
nonprofit manager for vision we have agency
and I started feeling like you know my judgment was being second
guessed and you know and I and I just became very very unhappy and.
You know as as I became more unhappy at work I started taking that unhappiness out
at home. On and I think that then
accelerated the end of the marriage
. I'm not sure it would've come anyway but. On. My knee
and that's I think why it was easy for me to blame myself. For so long.
Right because you know I was the one who was so miserable and I would wake
up in the morning and start bitching about something anything you know just because I didn't want to go
to work and I didn't want to deal with it and as time went on because I went I stayed at
that place three more years you know. It just got worse and worse
and I got more and more angry. That must have been really hard to live with.
You know where my memory is working in the technology. Did
you did you have a they were before that it was that with a whip
.
Yeah when I first I mean of course you know my
first earliest jobs were at a university is all my fellowships
on.
So that was like researching type work. On. It
. And then.
When I came back to New York in eighty nine and I didn't know what I was going
to do because I was like I have trained to be a college professor.
But I couldn't be a college professor because I didn't have my Ph D. and I
didn't and so I.
But I had learned to you know to use computer technology and I was really good at it
you know and this was back when it was you know it was
and that sort of you know command line oriented text oriented
operating system so it was really easy for blind people to to learn because there was no
point and click. There were no more icons there were no graphics. Everything was done through
typing Manzi or memorizing function keys and we actually
had a big advantage with that because as most of us have better memory is for that
kind of thing because we practice them especially back in the pre really pre-computer
days.
So I started looking for jobs teaching teaching Putins
. And the first couple jobs like God.
On were the very first I worked
just transcription typing for journalists. Friend of mine had a
friend who was working you know it was a freelance writer
and I did you know like I transcribe lots of interviews for him and for colleagues
and then Tom my friend and I also did some ghostwriting for him because we were a freelance writer who
take every single assignment because you can't turn down work but you can always write
everything so he would just pass us stuff we write and then he did it you
know. But I was terrified but the real first job I got was at La Guardia
Community College in a program called Computer Olympics
and it was a summer program and it was for kids fourteen
to sixteen.
You know what is euphemistically described as what are they say are at risk. Which you know
again usually means black and brown kids you know
. So she encouraged
instead computers are fun and school is fun and you should stay in school.
So all on and indeed I was the only the only white instructor in
the in the program.
Well there was a young man Caucasian man was like a lab tech
but it was a great experience I really love the people I worked with.
Sandy Watson I got to give her a shout out she said Dean. Now it already in
the workforce development program. She's amazing woman.
I learned so much from her. I mean just her attitude you
know when this blind woman walked in to teach classes to interview
for a position teaching classes all Sandy did was come over to me and say now. And
she was you know a language that is you know politically super practical you know.
I see you're differently abled or something like that you know she said So what can I do. What do I need to
do to help. Right and I thought this is beautiful. I cannot
believe this woman is just like not saying you're blind you can't work here or because I
don't have that kind of experience you know before in job interviews even they flat out
said it or they clearly thought it
interesting and were smart enough not to say it again so creating a
so.
A state was but you know whatever.
So Sandy hired me and I taught that program and then there was another
program that they had gotten a grant for called
. I want to see a job were
bound but that's not what it was called but it was like that it was you know at a basic GED
GED prep and then or three tracks I think for the kids could go
through either computer training you know computer
applications food service or automotive and so I taught the computer
piece. And this was all so I think it's mind you but it was
really easy and you know I was word perfect and Lotus and D. base
back when we had an accessible database of used. And you know
interesting the kids loved the bass that was their favorite product to work on
. And I stayed there a good two years I stayed there until I
got offered my position at Lighthouse which in I got in one thousand nine hundred two
but I also at the time I also interviewed before work while I was still because I was a
part time job I also got a job with a level ninety nine the
Consortium for workers education is part of you know and there I was teaching like
retired union members to learn computers
. But my real first big job job
was with lighthouse in one thousand nine hundred ninety two as an assistant tech
instructor and that was I was twenty nine. And it was a full time
job with benefits and a real salary and of course it was in White Plains
So that was a schlep. I did that for seven years man I mean
by by the time mid ninety's came around as I mentioned earlier when I was on my
last will and testament you know I got a few promotions that I was working both
out of the White Plains office and you know and I had some staff out there that could do a lot of
the work for me at White Plains. So I also that work at fifty ninth Street office which was much more
convenient and I was there you know till ninety nine and then
I was sent to New York Medical College for a little while Westchester Institute for Human
Development. We left because it was too hard to be
with with a lighthouse like take the train into White Plains you know the measure of
the earth and I could just walk to the lighthouse was like four or five block walk. But with that house
I had to. Take care. Of my putting the train to
North White Plains and taking a little shuttle bus on to the medical college campus
but that was less than I ever worked with an orientation and mobility specialist
because the other track. The stationary North white
is really like true it's a double edge platform and there's all kinds
of like a banshee isn't any sign I mean
it just felt so unsafe and I as I've said I have you know balance
problems and I just didn't I was scared to take the train and so
you know it just became too expensive and and also you know if I wasn't going
to go back and do a Ph D. there was really not going to be any future for me there.
So but the only other words that I ever do that was not what assistive type
oriented I mean certainly my last job where I was like the director of a department
and oversaw the computers as well as employment and
you know and in youth development programs but the only other job I
had didn't really involve tech so much
was when I was with the American Foundation for the blind.
I was there from two thousand and one
. To two thousand and five and I was the project coordinator for
. A project called the nationally standardized minimum
dataset and that was looking into. What
data should be collected on from.
You know the older blind programs. What data should we have
teachers.
Collect. In order to get it and how should it be
collected in order to get. A sort of nationally.
Standardized snapshot. Of what people's older blind
folks.
Abilities. And interests were and that was a
program that existed project existed in both the.
Policy about policy research and program evaluation Department and the
Department of Aging at. A.F.P. so I got to work with
two really amazing women who are the CO principal
investigators a current Kirchner who was very very well known in the
blindness field she's written. Some amazing books
. On data collection and policy and then
Alberta or who was the director of the senior programs there
and she said and that's you know Grant is retired. She's well into her seventy's
. And. I think. That's right. I mean
I learned about policy research and program evaluation and how do
you collect and analyze data and look at it in meaningful
ways and that has really driven.
The. Successive developments in my career that's how I think I
became such a successful grants writer because I knew how
to. Make something outcomes
oriented and say Here are the outcomes we predict and here's how we're going to
get there and that's all because of what I've learned. Working underground in Alberta
. In fact you know I still always entertain the idea of going back to
school because that's why that's my bent but I chose kind email from the
N.Y.U. alumni program office that N.Y.U. as a
master's in quantitative. Data Usage or something like that
quantitative analysis and I you know I got high when I saw it.
It's like this is exactly exactly what I want to do but I can you know I
don't think I can. I don't I can't certainly can't afford to go back to N.Y.U.
now unless I got the commission to pay for it but I guess I could work
that you know.
I'm quite sure if I decided to go back to school I could get you know get another
fellowship that it's really not that hard you just have to be willing you know to
work at a menial job. And all and get
a little bit of money but get your wish and paid for. But I you know that's I think
something that young people especially young blind people don't really think about
. And I'm not sure they're counseled about it. Well it depends on the
counselors some counselors are great at you know but you know I don't think
kids realize when I was a friend of mine you know in your sixty's and a
few years ago and I said I don't know I kind of want to go back to school but I want you to
see if we can find money you can always find them you know I think that's true. You know I do think
that's true. So my you know. After I left Penn
I was like well you know I would have had my Ph D. by the time I was thirty if I'd stayed
on. Then when I left I was always planning on finishing well get it by the time thirty
five that we met and then I thought well by the time I'm forty I could still do it and then in
my forty's I think you know I could still do this but it's fifty.
So now I'm fifty two and like you know if I sat down and if I do it
now I could still have it by the time I'm sixty I could still have fifteen to
twenty more years of a career at a college you know which is what I would have wanted so
.
I'll. End on this note I saw a. Report
this morning that said there is actually significant
.
Data academic research now showing. That
. Our myths about aging that we have so many myths about aging is
one of the biggest myths is that people become more
depressed and happy as they grow older.
And it turns out that that's not true that there's a
period in the late forty's early fifty's where people get a little
anxious and. Aren't sure. Right. But then we had
fifty years and all. People are just. Life gets better
. People are happier. I mean there's there's significant data to indicate that
this is true. So. You know I'm feeling like
OK you know I'll be fifty three in three months you know
four months and.
So that's you know. That's headed into a good.
Yeah I don't know
if you have anything else that you and I and I think this is
a good thing like these folks have a lot you
know.
Well thank you it's been it's been a pleasure. It's been my pleasure
. I
. Mean I am. Me.
Let's. Go.